gracias por la invitación mira esto es
algo importante que hay que aclarar
todavía no es suficiente evidencia para
determinar si escapan o no de la
inmunidad que crea la vacuna
específicamente para ellos pero aún así
las vacunas que tenemos para el
coronavirus ayudan a entrenar al sistema
inmune y de esta manera logramos dos
cosas una desde el caso de que se
presenten la enfermedad sea más leve y
dos de que no se produzcan más variantes
en el futuro tenemos que continuar con
una alta tasa de vacunación si realmente
queremos terminar esta pandemia y
terminar con la creación de variante
doctor en su opinión no será necesario
adaptar los preparados en cuánto tiempo
estarían listos y qué tan seguros serían
para su inyección masiva
tenemos que recordar que ya estas nuevas
vacunas están diseñadas de una manera
que es más fácil en el huesito principal
como para decirlo así colocar la nueva
información sobre esa estructura no
tardarían tanto como se producen otras
vacunas sin embargo para tomar las
medidas de seguridad y de efectividad y
determinarlo podría tardar de unos dos
meses a tres meses para que pudieran
estar de nuevo disponibles para la
población general bueno usted ha sido
muy clara en que la vacunación no yo
tendría que ser la solución qué más
podemos hacer para contener a un
microondas
mira tenemos que continuar vacunando eso
es una parte de la solución la otra es
continuar con las medidas de mitigación
que es el uso de mascarillas lavado de
manos frecuente y distanciamiento social
entiendo que las personas a nivel global
están cansadas de esto pero se ha
demostrado ser muy eficaz en combinación
con las vacunas así que tenemos que
continuar con este tipo de medidas hasta
que realmente este virus se vuelva el de
mí pues a ustedes un agradecimiento por
este análisis y sobre todo por la
información